[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me is an
author and associate professor of
philosophy at the College of William and
Mary Chris Fryman
welcome to the Rubin report thanks for
having me all right man we're gonna do
philosophy for an hour are you ready
sounds good yeah you are prepared
I feel the jacket shirt combo it's very
philosophy I said give me the Reuben
yeah all right let's talk philosophy
because I think one of the things that I
try to do on this show is I talk about
philosophies more than people ideas
board than people and it seems to me we
live in a time where we don't do a lot
of philosophy and idea stuff well and I
guess that's maybe why why people are
watching this so let's do a little
philosophy 101 okay with you give me
just some of the basics of what people
should understand about philosophy okay
well yeah it's a great question yes I
might take the hour but yeah so I think
you know at the fundamental level
philosophy is about challenging
assumptions I think one thing that makes
philosophy different from other sorts of
academic disciplines is that you can't
really take anything for granted so when
you're you know doing philosophy you
have to justify why killing people is
wrong for example why feeding the hungry
is good and all of these things that we
take for granted at the level of
everyday life philosophy calls into
question and I think that's really
important and so the kinds of
philosophical questions that I'm most
interested in are ones having to do with
moral right and wrong justice injustice
the moral importance of economic
equality these sorts of things and also
the the ethics of public policy so for
example one thing that non philosophical
disciplines can do is make predictions
about what a given policy is likely to
do so while opening the borders lead to
higher unemployment higher GDP something
like that but all things considered they
can't really tell us what the right
thing to do is we say okay suppose it
turns out that opening borders will
slightly increase domestic unemployment
but it also will mean that certain
workers in the developing world will see
their incomes rise by 300% for example
this leaves open the question what
should we do
is that a trade-off that we should make
and that's really what philosophy tries
to answer is what should we do all
things considered alright so in a little
bit we're gonna get to some of your
moral philosophies that you care about
in economic philosophies and immigration
and a bunch of other things in just a
little bit but first I'm curious what
got you interested in philosophy in the
first place yeah that's a good question
so I think it was doing philosophy
before I realized I was doing philosophy
because arguing what's a good-natured
arguing was the family tradition in my
household so ever since I was a little
kid you know my parents and my sister
and I we would argue about religion and
politics and these sorts of things right
and wrong the economy and when I got a
little bit older I started reading
things and philosophy and economics
columns articles and things like that
and I realized that there was this kind
of formal discipline called philosophy
where you could argue about right and
wrong and justice and injustice and if
you were very lucky you could get a job
doing this if I get paid to do this not
a lot of not a lot of jobs not paid very
much either
but it's kind of like saying you know
you can get paid to eat ice cream for a
living I thought okay that's that's a
pretty good gig if I can get it and you
know that was kind of the start of the
trajectory into philosophy yeah you know
it's interesting because I came from a
very similar family in that regard where
we argued about everything from
economics and religion and all of those
things and I guess perhaps it this is
what led you here it's kind of what led
me here as well but we're missing that
these days don't you think like that
must infuriate you as someone that cares
about ideas when you watch the news and
watch all these people that are aren't
arguing from like a principled position
or something like a philosophically
thought-out position but just from like
a party place or a partisan place must
drive you nuts
it does it does because right I care
about ideas I care fundamentally about
good arguments so this is something that
I hope happens to my students in my
classes is they come in with a set of
preconceptions they have you know
they're partisan political believes
everybody does I have my partisan
political beliefs but I hope we can try
as hard as we can to just focus on the
argue
think critically and maybe change our
minds even if it means admitting that we
were wrong or you know finding out that
we have different political or religious
beliefs from our friends you should
really just follow wherever the
arguments lead us do you actually like
it when you find out you were wrong on
something cuz when I've had the moments
on this show and the most famous one is
when I had Larry elder in here and he
just kind of beat me senseless with
facts and you know and we've since
become friends and he was on just
recently and and I love the guy yeah
that it was scary in the moment like
sitting there in the moment of being
beaten is not fun but afterwards when
you go whoa that's what it's about it's
actually pretty cool yes so I don't like
like is it in the moment I don't like
being threatened by because I got a
couple things I'm gonna but but
long-term I think that's right it shows
growth and the funny thing is that what
are we afraid of when it comes to
changing our mind and admitting we're
wrong what's really the harm in that and
I really I like the process of arguing
it's you know a form of recreation or
something like a form of exercise I
think I think was Edmund Burke who said
something like the person who challenged
my adversary is actually my best friend
or something like this so the person
that is willing to argue with you in
good faith and genuinely cares about
getting at what's true rather than what
maybe confirms their prior political
beliefs that's you know that's person
that I want to hang out with yes I want
to talk with one of my best friends
growing up his name Derry Greek so he
was all into Greek philosophy and all
that and he was my intellectual sparring
partner for them from from literally
from 12 years old till well past college
even now and we're on eclis we actually
agree more now than ever before which is
sort of weird because we both had sort
of reverse philosophical journeys or
political journeys but that's actually
what it's all about so tell me a little
bit about some of the philosophers that
have affected you so one of my favorites
is probably John Stuart Mill so he was a
classical liberal he so he's what's
known as a utilitarian and this is a
moral theory that essentially says the
right thing to do is the thing that has
the best consequences the thing that
produces the most happiness for
everybody who's affected I find that
view attractive in moral philosophy but
he was also a he was a
Bosko liberal politically he was a big
defender of free speech free discussion
in particular his book on liberty is
probably the single greatest defense of
freedom of speech
I travel with it you know I'm on tour
right now I travel with it it's a thin
book yeah everyone should have it yeah
that's right
yeah so what okay so you mentioned
classical liberalism
okay everyone knows my feelings on this
do you see any meaningful distinction
between classical liberalism and
libertarianism at this point I think
that libertarianism is probably a bit
narrower than classical liberalism so
but this is a matter of debate I don't
have a very firm opinion on this but
when I think of a libertarian I think of
somebody who says the state should do
the following three things have a court
system have police force and maybe
enforce contracts something like that no
more maybe some kind of very small
social minimum Milton Friedman negative
income tax type thing whereas they think
classical liberals are more friendly to
a more active state but I would also say
that I'm happy to say that libertarians
are part of the classical liberal family
yeah it's funny because I had Dom
Boudreaux in here a couple weeks ago
talking about this and I fall on that
path where the more I go down the
libertarian route I really like that
line of thinking I still think there's
some utility of the state yeah but I
think the more that you have these
conversations for me I'm finding it
harder and harder to defend anything
related to the state which is it I guess
I'm taking a philosophically fair
approach to this because I'm taking in
new information yeah yeah I I'm I'm the
same way so I think that the the best
arguments for something like classical
liberalism or libertarianism is just the
pervasiveness of government failure so
you know you look at where actual
government money goes not just not in
theory but in practice where it goes
what sorts of groups are advantaged and
disadvantaged by the state the
government just doesn't work very well
and so the same reasons why we don't
want the government producing food for
example are also reasons why we might
not want the government in the business
of save running schools right so do you
think it would be fair to say that if it
well if this thing was a slim trim
operation and is financially sensible
and we had people of good moral
character and the gravamen and the rest
of it but you'd actually have no reason
to be certainly libertarian and me
perhaps even a classical liberal you
might actually be more of some sort of
big government Democrat or something
like that I think that's right at least
from my perspective so as I said I'm a
fan of mill and utilitarianism of the
idea that the right thing is the thing
that produces the best results and so I
think in a world in which the state was
run by angels very wise people very
benevolent people and it produced good
results I would be happy to accept a big
activist government a regulatory and
redistribute of state but I think there
are very powerful reasons for thinking
that that's not the world that we live
in so I think that some of my audience
when they hear you talk about Mill and
what's what's best for everyone they're
gonna view that through some sort of
lens of collectivism which is going to
set some bells off so can you unpack
that a little bit right yeah so I for
what it's worth my view is that a system
that produces the most happiness the
most flourishing the most prosperity is
something like a libertarian minimal
state perhaps with a small social
minimum so when you look historically at
collectivist regimes say the Soviet
Union or North Korea something like that
these don't have a good track record of
making people happy when you look at the
the societies that actually make people
happy compared to the alternative they
tend to be liberal limited government
free market civil libertarian ish kind
of states all right so what are their
philosophers that's back did you you're
one for one yeah John Stuart Mill right
up the top I'll give you somebody who
you might not like although you might
not be familiar with them Peter Singer
who's a contemporary utilitarian and a
lot of people I think a lot of classical
liberals and libertarians aren't big
fans of his although I think they they
need not not be fans of his so he's he's
famous for a number of things he has a
number of very controversial positions
on a lot of things but one of his more
famous thought experiments involves you
imagining that you're walking somewhere
and you pass a small child who's
drowning in a shallow
Pond and you can save this child at a
very low cost to you all all that's
required is that you step into the pond
to get your shoes muddy and pull the
child out but this means you'll have to
spend diving all hundred bucks on new
shoes and he says clearly the sacrifice
of a hundred dollars worth of shoes is
worth saving this child and so this
suggests that we have strong obligations
to make personal sacrifices for the
betterment of the world's poor
maybe that's right as at the level of
moral principle for example but I think
a lot of libertarians and classical
liberals worry that what this is going
to mean is we ought to have large
welfare states we ought to have billions
of dollars channeled into foreign aid
and so on and I can understand why they
make that leap but I don't think that
follows especially again if you look at
the track record of whether or not the
government does a good job of helping
the poor and I think it generally
doesn't yeah so and I definitely want to
get to your thoughts on that so do you
view that sort of as like that's sort of
like a micro macro argument that at a
micro level yeah you'd probably do it
like I'm sure if either one of those
we're walking down the street we
wouldn't care that much about our shoes
and able to save somebody but at a
societal level which probably gets well
out of your economic arguments as well
the more that you keep giving over to
society the more that it keeps taking
yeah well so I think is individuals in
their private lives if they do a good
job of say researching which private
charities do a good job of alleviating
poverty in the developing world and I
think there are some then we would have
in some sense in some sense a societal
obligation to help just in the sense
that most people of means have this
obligation to say donate some of their
paycheck to the against malaria
foundation for example but I think that
doesn't justify saying we want the state
in the business of redistributing income
on a global level if only because it
just doesn't do a very good job of it
and oftentimes makes poverty even worse
alright so you are a blogger at bleeding
heart libertarian yes and I've seen the
site before and I checked it out again
before before you got here but I thought
the phrase bleeding heart libertarians
that sort of sounds like what a
classical liberal is right we got a
little a little more heart in essence
we're okay with a little more state yeah
hopefully make sure the people who need
it the most are okay but I think a lot
of people will see those terms at odds
bleeding-heart libertarian ya know and
that's a great a great point too in
light of the conversation about Peter
Singer because they do think that we
have and I think a lot of classical
liberals agree that we have this strong
obligation to uphold political
institutions that work particularly well
for the poor and this isn't job
bleeding-heart libertarians is knew this
isn't just something that popped up in
the last five or six years if you go all
the way back to Adam Smith he has this
this argument about the division of
labor and free trade he says you know
you were sitting at your desk trying to
make pins all by yourself maybe you
could do two or three in a day you have
a division of labor where one person
straighten the wire the other person's
putting a pin on the on the wire and so
forth makes us massively more productive
than we otherwise could be and then
through free trade or everybody's
welfare is increased but he stresses
that this is particularly good for the
poor because he says a society in which
we're very productive and we have this
abundance of material goods is a society
in which these sorts of goods are going
to be a lot cheaper and this is in fact
what we see and so a society in which
the real price of not just necessities
but also things that we might consider
luxuries like smartphones or something a
society that makes those abundant and
cheap is a society that's very good for
the poor so I think a bleeding-heart
libertarian or classical perspective is
hundreds of years old although you
probably we haven't done a good job of
marketing ourselves perhaps yeah how
would you actually define what good is
that's a tough one yeah so that's right
yeah that's that's a big question so
here's the evasive answer is that it
depends on which philosopher you're
talking yeah so some philosophers think
that so Mill has this view that the good
consists of pleasure but it's a
sophisticated view where some pleasures
are of higher quality than others so if
I don't know you have pleasure as a
result of shooting up heroin and that's
equal in intensity and duration to the
pleasure that you get from reading
Shakespeare there's something
qualitatively better about the
Shakespeare than the heroine and so
that's his view is that it's a life of
pleasure but where you have these
higher and lower pleasures other people
other utilitarians think all pleasures
created equal
other people have maybe more complicated
views where a bunch of stuff makes a
life good so its pleasure its knowledge
its living a morally virtuous life and
so on and this is a debate that we've
been having for 200 or 2,500 years yeah
no end in sight I sense I know where you
stand on that but do you want to
elaborate on that a little more well so
I think that yes it's a good cause
you're here yeah I'm here so what what
is good well so I think that good for a
particular person is probably what a
philosopher would call the satisfaction
of your informed preferences so
essentially getting what you want if you
know what it is that you're getting so
for example you might want the liquid
that is in a glass right now because you
have the belief that its water but if
you have the fault if that belief is
false because it turns out to be vodka
or something like that you might have a
desire for what's in there but the
desire is in some sense informed by this
false belief but if you have perfectly
true beliefs about the world and then
you've desired say that cup of water I'd
say well that's good for you to get that
water you're getting what you want yeah
so you basically believe that
selfishness is good no because I think
that a lot of people I think most people
in fact have preferences rational
preferences for the welfare of other
people so I would say you know most can
you make it a selfish argument for that
because the way I've always sort of
understand or at least the way I use
these words now is that by doing what is
good for me that doesn't mean I want to
ransack the entire world right I want to
do good so that it's good for my
community I want to take care of my own
house
so that my neighbor hopefully will be
like I'm next door to someone with a
nice house and we're gonna take care of
their eyes so I view selfish and I guess
that's a little more of an eye on Rann
thing where I view selfishness actually
as a virtue yeah so I think the
difference would be in at say a case
where you're you're walking and see the
child drowning on the shallow pond the
question would be well what is the
reason why you're saving this child and
and ruining their boots I think a good
answer to that is well because they care
about the child's welfare and in some
times it's true
that's a preference that you have so
it's your preference until you could
call it a sort of self guided or self
directed preference but I wouldn't call
it a selfish preference in the sense
that you expect in some sense this
child's welfare to directly translate
into benefits for you right but you
would feel good after I get it like you
wouldn't if you'd be a pretty twisted
person if you were like well walking by
you like well well how's that gonna make
me feel right after though you should
you should do what's right but I know
what's right can often lead to all sorts
of bad things yeah but I think you could
make a selfish argument for that like
you know that if you walk by a child
that you could easily help and you don't
you're gonna feel shitty after if you
have any shred of conscious right right
so I hope right so most non sociopaths I
hope have that have that sort of
psychological disposition and as far as
sort of what so I think also what
morality is more concerned with is not
just the good of the individual but sort
of the good of all so I think for what
the morally right thing to do is
figuring out the decision so this is the
kind of million utilitarian view that
the right thing to do is basically that
which produces the most good for
everybody not just an individual person
so it could be in some cases that a
person's individual good comes apart
from what's morally good so you could
imagine somebody who just has no desire
to help other people I would still say
they're doing something morally wrong if
they fail to help other people because
they're not taking that person's welfare
into account right so where do you think
morals come from this has been an
ongoing discussion on this show but
young you know talking to Jordan Peters
in a bench peer and Sam Harris and
Michael Shermer Dennis Prager and many
others and they're sort of a religious
argument I think there's a secular
argument for it I think I'm somewhere in
the middle I think it's a really rich
spot to figure out what people think
about things yeah so that's that's a
that's a hard question I'm not sure I
have a satisfying answer to that so but
maybe in terms of the religious question
there's this very old argument from
Plato the Euthyphro dilemma I'm not sure
if that's ever popped up in conversation
but the idea is basically does God will
something because it's pious
independently of God's will or is it
pious because God wills it and Plato's
view was well it doesn't quite make
sense to say that it's pious just
because God wills it because you could
imagine as a thought experiment that God
willing all sorts of terrible thing just
as a thought experiment that you know if
God willed us to torture it doesn't seem
like that would make torture good and so
it seems more plausible to think that
there is sort of an independent standard
of goodness even even if you were a
theist for example and you believe in
God and you believe God has this
intimate connection to morality I think
even on views like that it makes sense
to say that goodness is in some sense
independent of the will of God and so in
terms of what more that's a again sort
of an evasive answer as to what it's not
where morality comes from I mean I'm
inclined to say I mean it comes from or
what's good for human beings and maybe
other sentient animals so what sorts of
things satisfy our interests satisfy our
Preferences causes pleasure and pain the
sorts of things do you think that's
subjective though that different
cultures obviously have different
beliefs and different you know
moralities and all sorts of things I
would say it is not subjective in the in
the sense that different different
cultures having different moral beliefs
would show that nobody's wrong in those
debates so it might be very difficult to
determine who is wrong but I don't think
the mere fact that different cultures
have moral standards shows that it's
subjective so by analogy you could
imagine different cultures having
different beliefs about astrology for
example so some cultures think that
astrology is legitimate enterprise other
ones don't they disagree about that but
I think it's safe to say that there is
in some sense an objectively correct
answer about that same thing with other
sorts of scientific disputes right but
do you think that that objective place
does that have to come from God per se
or can it come from I mean the
discussion that we've had a lot around
here and that a lot of people in this
space talk about basically is does
objective morality either come from God
and religion or does it come from
enlightenment values and then there's
other arguments that it's only through
religion that we got to enlightenment
values right in the first place yeah
that's tough my hunch is that something
like enlightenment values so I don't
know I'm somewhere in the eggnog
dick space myself and so I think that
your philosophy guy right exactly so
it's hard not to it's it's hard not to
be an agnostic so yeah so I'm agnostic
but I'm also Jewish and so there's it's
all are the kind of questioning lack of
certainty and so forth right so I think
that there is that there's enough reason
to think that we have objective morality
even if you're not certain about the
existence of God that yeah we shouldn't
worry that morality is going to collapse
if people become atheist and agnostic
right cuz when I've had this discussion
usually with conservatives you know they
love to say well God gave us morality
United I mean your rights come from God
and for me it's like I think you have
whether they're got you know god-given
rights or it's your right freedom is
your right as a human being yeah or as
Optimus Prime said freedom is the right
of all sentient beings
you know like I think you are born free
I just think that's a that's a
humanistic approach or you're born free
the government can take away your
freedom it doesn't give it to you and I
think that's just a really interesting
place to go for all these political
discussions I I agree so I that's why I
think that there are right and wrong
ways to treat other human beings that
are just true independently of whether
or not the the state happens to respect
them and this is the kind of
enlightenment thought so John Locke said
look in the state of nature I would be
wrong to kill you or assault you or
steal your property this is just the
wrong way to treat human beings it
doesn't really have anything to do with
the state now we might want the state to
come in and protect those rights and
force those rights and so on but the
rights themselves the standard of the
right and wrong way to treat other
people does not itself come from the
state all right so before we get into
some of your the specific arguments they
make on economics in a budget how do you
think our founders got so much of this
stuff right if I'm going on the
assumption you believe they did right
but I mean every time I go to DC and I
go to the monuments and I read all of
this stuff and I just was in Philly
yesterday I mentioned to you and I have
now a copy of that little copy of a
Republican senator of the Declaration of
Independence off the alarm at the
resisting with like it would set off the
TSA alarms at oh this one's just
standard simple paper whatever
probably I'll set off some alarm
somewhere I'm sure if I go to San
Francisco or something I'm sure a
constitution would set off an alarm but
I assume you think that they got a much
of this stuff correctly how do you think
they did it yeah so I think that's I
don't know so I think that some of it
this is a bit outside of my my own area
but I think that a lot of them were
influenced by smart philosophers people
like so I think the law the influence of
someone like lock on the Constitution is
pretty evident the influence of somebody
like David Hume on people like Madison I
think that's I think that maybe that's a
matter of controversy in history but I
think there's some evidence to suggest
that so I think that they were students
of history students of philosophy
students of economics and this helped
them get a lot right and I think you
know obviously I think there were
mistakes in the way that they applied it
and you know the way that like
Jefferson's omission of mentions of
slavery and things like that but I think
in terms of like the fundamentals a lot
of that was informed by really smart
philosophers and economists yeah well
they were they were all philosophers in
their own right and you know they were
inconsistent as people in in their own
time which is why I'm so fascinated with
that period of history all right so
let's talk about some of the specifics
here so I wanted to go to one that I
think we disagree on but I want you to I
want you to make the most compelling
case that you can this open borders
stuff yes I'm not an open borders guy
this is a I'm not a crazy borders person
whatever that means I don't think I
don't think there should be no
immigration we are a nation of
immigrants that's what's made this
melting pot I think the greatest nation
in the history of the world that's
giving more freedom to more people than
than anyone ever but the open border
situation especially now in 2018 2018
strikes me as particularly tenuous
particularly yeah good so I think one
thing to keep in mind is what exactly an
advocate of open borders is arguing for
so I think most so open borders is maybe
a bit of a misnomer it's more like
borders or porous borders or something
like that where so the idea wouldn't be
that there's perhaps no checkpoints or
no restrictions on immigration just very
few so I think most open border folks
would be happy
that if you are a wanted violent
criminal that might exclude you from
immigrating if you have some
particularly deadly contagious disease
and so forth but other than that for
ordinary peaceful migrants should be
able to come to the United States as far
as the the argument goes I think they're
really two strands one is just that the
the economic benefits of immigration are
huge so the most optimistic estimates
say that we could potentially double
worlds at GDP by opening borders so
we've done a pretty good job opening up
trade we've done a much worse job
opening up borders but in terms of the
productivity gains it would be
incredible better than anything else we
could do and this goes back to what I
was discussing earlier with our
obligations to the global poor foreign
aid doesn't have a good track record
military intervention doesn't have a
good track record but allowing people to
move from places with low wages to
higher wages is by far the best
anti-poverty tool that we have so if we
were gonna get into the nitty-gritty of
some of that what do you actually have
to do then to secure the borders right
because that's really what this is about
so even if if you make every economic
argument that I'm like all right I can't
riddle my way out of that Yeah right
like if I'm on board that you still have
to do something to make sure that you're
doing those things making sure that
murderers aren't coming in and all that
and we don't seem very good at that and
I think maybe that's the leap that gets
me to where I can't make the the
secondary part that you're talking about
here yeah so I'm not sure about the
policy specifics I mean something like
the old Ellis Island system seems pretty
good I mean we had a ton of immigration
back then but there still was some kind
of checking mechanism so as far so I
doubt that that involves building a wall
but having some kind of you know
centralized location where immigrants
can come and get documents and things
like that seems seems pretty reasonable
but that's probably the most detail I
could give you on policy ideas right so
then when you go over these borders then
your gut you would want these people to
be governed by the laws of the place
that they were in right act that's right
yeah yeah so I would be happy to write a
allow ordinary peaceful migrants to come
in and then apply for US citizenship
just you know
make it pretty easy to do that right is
this though a tough one for a guy that
doesn't trust the government that much
because that that's what's ringing with
me here and when I've heard this
argument it's like alright wait if you
don't trust the government well then why
do you think the government would be
able to vet people properly especially
because we now see what's going on in
Europe where they've vetted people very
poorly and I've had very porous borders
yeah so this might yeah so I don't know
I think though if you're a skeptic of
the government so presumably you're a
free trade advocate you like to get
across borders you wouldn't be happy
with government's micromanaging trade
across borders because you know a
skeptic about how all the government
works as am i and for the same sorts of
reasons I'm skeptical so I think if
you're worried about the government
working well that's all the more reason
to get it out of the immigration
regulation business so might in fact I
think you're probably right there's a
bad job of a lot of stuff almost
everything and so the standard here is
not going to be perfection but just
what's the best alternative heavily
regulated immigration or lightly
integrated regulation and I think all
things equal lightly and lightly
regulated immigration will probably be
better
I'll give you another argument too so
this again is maybe a more libertarian
classical liberal argument for
immigration but it just seems like
people have a right to move across
borders so for example if you know I
don't know this table for example were
divided by some kind of border and I
said well look I want you to come over
to my side and rent my house from me or
work in my business or join my religious
congregation and you said okay I do want
to do those things and we both agree on
this we agree on the terms and then the
state sort of intervenes is a third
party in this what this philosopher
Robert knows it could call a capitalist
act between consenting adults it seems
like they would be violating our rights
to associate with one another on three
terms and so I think there's a reason to
think that border controls violate
people's natural rights is there also
some inherent problem though that let's
say most of the Western societies the
freest societies got on board this well
then they would end up being flooded
with people where maybe the economics
don't work out because if we just say I
mean if you think about it like if
tomorrow we were dressed like alright
everybody can come and you tell me
you're not a murderer or you know you
know drug dealer you're good to go that
there must be some economic theory here
where we're gonna let in a certain
amount of people your economics are
gonna work out and then we're gonna get
to some odd tipping point where because
freedoms pretty good people go on in on
it yeah so I think there are a couple
things to say so one is just if we I
think that problem to some extent would
be self-correcting so if you think that
a lot of the pressure to migrate is
economic so people are moving from
low-wage countries to higher wage
countries well you have more and more
people answer about high wage higher
wage countries this would increase the
total number of workers which would
probably start dropping down their wages
and so you would probably see less
motivation to move I think that's one
thing but as a concession to this worry
what I would say is we could do it
slowly so for example if we're really
worried about these effects of
dramatically increasing immigration
overnight what we could do is just say
increase say the limits on immigration
by 10 percent every year or something
like that
and take it slowly and see where it goes
we wouldn't have to push the button open
the borders overnight if we have this
worry yeah what do you think is
philosophically the the soundest way to
deal with the people that are already
here I yeah so I am an advocate of the
view that you don't have an obligation
to obey unjust laws and so I think that
our immigration laws are unjust so I
think people who came here even against
current immigration law I think they
should just I'm Emma Steve Paul
citizenship that's that would be my
approach to that huh yeah
all right we're not quite there let me
ask you this so you're it's a you know
not a fan of the drug war no I'm not
okay so suppose we have somebody who I
don't know is in jail for selling
marijuana yeah like this and then
suppose that yeah so the break was a
citizen of the United props a current
immigration or not immigration current
drug laws yeah do you think that they
violated some moral obligation that they
had not to break us drug law or do you
say well what was a bad law so they
didn't do anything well
well partly I think it would depend on
the specific offense so so whether they
were using drugs or selling drugs I
would see a distinction there so okay if
there's someone that and there are
people that are in jail for using drugs
right now for using pot I think those
those laws are unjust and I would want
to do everything I could to reverse
those laws and reverse the the prison
system the justice system and all that
as far as the dealers
yeah you can't until until we fix these
laws and figure out what actually is
fair and change some classifications on
marijuana and a bunch of other things
it's tough I think it's tough I don't
think you can free drug dealers per se
okay even though you're you don't think
they did something that should be
against the law the people that are
doing the drugs I think you have a right
to do with your body as you see fit but
okay but again if you break a law you
have like I would change the laws is
what I'm saying
but if you break a law then you have to
suffer the consequences of that
so exactly do that all again well but
I'm curious I don't know forgive me for
but so suppose you have a drug user
who's convicted of this offense yeah
they're in jail but suppose they can
escape from prison
you're armless Lee do you think they
would be doing something morally wrong
by escaping from prison
all right so this is a good little all
right we're doing a little so this is
great I mean this is what it's about
right so okay so let's say someone was
smoking weed at home cops bust in
they're thrown in jail for three years
year two and they're gonna pull a
Shawshank and get out of there right do
I think they're morally the question is
do I think they're morally right for
doing it or it cannot be morally
justified yes
so right so would we morally criticize
them if right they pull the shawshank
where they escape through the wall or
something like that and they don't harm
anyone they just they just leave because
they say I was convicted of something
that ought not be a crime so I don't owe
any morally moral allegiance to that law
and so I'm just going to escape would
you hear about this story do you say I'd
be rooting for that okay yeah I would be
rooting for that so that's kind of my
perspective on immigration that I think
that it's an unjust law and so people
just as people aren't under an
obligation to obey the state with
respect to the drug war yeah I don't
think people are under an obligation
Toby the state with respect to
immigration right so I guess our sort of
disconnect on this is just the
unjustness
migration laws versus drug laws right
right so if you think that the law
itself is not unjust then my argument
won't have any kind of grip on you yeah
I'm not saying our immigration laws are
just by the way I just think that
especially now also just because of
terrorism and people move and just when
you see what's going on with Europe and
and because it hasn't just been people
trying to get over for humanitarian
purposes there we know that there's a
lot of migrants and all sorts of other
people and then assimilation problems
and then welfare state problems like it
just seems like it's become this massive
thing that most of Europe would probably
do it very differently if they could
look back eight years ago right yeah so
as far as the terrorism point goes I
mean I think if somebody is is a1 to
terrorists or suspected terrorists
that's a perfectly legitimate reason not
to not to allow the men I'm less
concerned about the the assimilation
concern the welfare state concern so as
as far as the the assimilation where he
goes I mean a lot of the the evidence
I've seen suggests that the political
values of immigrants and especially
second-generation American immigrants is
almost identical to the political
political values held by native-born
Americans and as far as the welfare
state concern goes I would say we have
lots of other freedoms that can
potentially increase the cost of the
welfare state and we're okay with people
exercising them so for example you know
I don't know we allow people to choose
their own profession for example in the
United States and so suppose you have a
student who says here's what I want to
do with my life I want to become a
philosopher you say well that's you know
I see career choice not a lot of money
in it who knows maybe you'll end up on
unemployment yeah and this will in fact
increase the cost of the welfare state
because now you have this person on
unemployment because they chose to
become a philosopher what their life we
say well we let them do that we let them
exercise that freedom to choose that
occupation even knowing that this might
increase the costs of the welfare state
and so I think you can make an analogous
argument about immigration if you think
it's a right and important human freedom
then you say well this is sort of a
price of respecting rights and
respecting freedom they sometimes can
impose costs on third parties yeah so if
all these people come here that
what what duty does the state have to
make sure that they don't just get here
and can't do anything and then then more
crime comes and drugs and the rest of it
yeah is there a responsibility for the
state at that point I'm not sure that
the responsibility of the state to
immigrants is different from their
responsibility to citizens so I think
part so I mean there's also a question
of what we would do in the ideal world
versus the real world so you say in the
ideal world of somebody like Milton
Friedman the welfare state is much
smaller maybe you have something like
the negative income tax this isn't the
world we live in we have over a trillion
dollars of redistributed spending every
year I mean I don't so there are two
separate issues so one is this empirical
claim about whether immigrants tend to
consume more in government services than
they pay in taxes and it seems like the
fiscal effect is pretty moderate so some
estimates say they do in fact raise
fiscal costs a little bit others say no
in fact actually there a net benefit
because a lot of a lot of new immigrants
aren't consuming a lot of government
services and so forth and they're paying
sales tax and things like this but I
think though again this is like the
concession if you really have this thing
about the welfare say we could say well
maybe this is not my view but if if this
is what it took for me to get you over
to my side I'll give you this I'll give
you this concession we could say
something like you have a five-year
waiting period before you have access to
unemployment benefits and whatnot I
would take that over board or closure if
those were the only two operating it's
tough being intellectually honest isn't
it because you have to get you have to
concede things every now and again which
you just don't see people doing anymore
so it seems like doubly that's just this
is just a ploy to get you and your
viewers to the Lord on my side so yeah I
don't care so much about the honesty
just get people on the open border side
all right so you've argued that
inequality of income isn't the real
issue but poverty is the real issue
right let's get into the weeds on that
okay good so sometimes you'll hear this
is sometimes philosophers but oftentimes
politicians they'll make statements like
2% of American earners have 40% of that
country's wealth or something like that
and from here we're supposed to infer
that
injustice has occurred because there's
this this large enough quality and I
think I mean there might be an injustice
there but we can't tell strictly on the
basis of the inequality so there's a
philosopher named Robert Nozick who
famously said what matters isn't so much
the income distribution that we end up
with but how we got there so if somebody
has a huge amount of wealth but they got
it through theft or they got it through
lobbying the government for special
privileges this is very bad this is
something that we shouldn't encourage on
the other hand if we have somebody who
has a lot of wealth because they
invented the iPhone and there are tens
if not hundreds of millions of people
who want to buy this that's totally fine
so we can't just look at the pie and how
its carved up and say whether it's just
or unjust we have to see that people
make their money by making other people
better off by giving them things that
they wanted or did they take it through
fraudulent means coercive means and I
think that the talk about inequality
oftentimes confuses equality with
poverty so is what we're really
concerned with equalizing income or are
we concerned about making the poor
better off and I think it's the latter
that we really should care about so how
do we go ahead and do that well so
opening borders I think is the first
step in terms of alleviating global
inequality or I'm sorry global poverty I
think is the best thing that we can do I
think domestically there are a lot of
government policies that really do harm
to the most disadvantaged groups so I
think opening up school choice would be
a great idea I think I think the drug
war would be a great idea I think ending
occupational licensing would be a very
good idea so enabling people to work in
certain industries or start their own
business with a lot less red tape is a
very good and wouldn't barbers be
stabbing people with scissors there are
some states where you have to you have
to get a license to shampoo people yeah
but I shampoo my ID and put my hair
every morning you doing this unless you
know it's and I probably shouldn't say
that yeah I do
I should myself like you know comb my
hair without a license and so far the
government hasn't come after me and I
haven't you know poked my eye out yeah
so what's your all right so what's your
best argument that when when the people
that don't buy into this and say
we need these regulations because you're
gonna have people that don't know how to
dye hair are gonna be scalding people's
heads and you know mr. burns is gonna be
dumping nuclear waste into the
Springfield River and all of those
things yeah that's the best argument
against it well so one argument is just
that I don't think regulation works very
well and I don't think so I think the
way that the public views regulation is
probably misguided so I don't think that
regulators are bad people but I think if
you examine the ways that regulations
are formed and operate in the real world
it's oftentimes to protect the in the
interests of the industries that the
regulating so this is what's known as
regulatory capture where regulators
aren't always looking out for the public
interest they're actually looking out
for the interest of people in that
industry so financial regulation is a
case of this you have lobbyists who
might be friends with people in the
financial sector they want to work in
the financial sector later or vice versa
and so they're often very friendly to
the very people that they're regulating
and as far as you know the worry about
you know scalding people and so forth I
think that competition itself is a kind
of regulation so in the case of school
choice it's true you might have very bad
charter schools for example but again
the the standard here is not perfection
the standard is what's the alternative
so we have public schools that are
terrible yeah but charter schools have
this advantage of enabling people to
choose so if you go to a charter school
that's failing you can pull your kids
out and put them somewhere else and
that's a kind of regulation in the sense
that it provides incentives to the
providers to supply good service so it's
almost like we should rely on
self-regulation yeah yeah not even self
regulation in the sense so this is
something that comes up when I when I
argue with people is they think that I
have this view of private business as as
being sort of benevolent where they'll
just take care of themselves I've a
sense of the public interest I think
maybe to some extent that's true but
it's more that they're kind of smithy
and insight where if you have providers
who are competing for my business they
don't have to care about my welfare
directly or the welfare of my family but
they might just want my money and that
itself is an incentive for them to
provide good safe service so in a sense
it's competition for dollars comput
for customers that acts as the
regulation so I think the market as a
whole is self-regulating or
self-correcting yeah so you're also a
universal basic income supporter yeah
now usually this is a idea that comes
from economists on the left I've heard
some interesting sort of libertarian
arguments from it from people but what
is your take on so this goes back to the
idea that it is important to take care
of people who are in poverty or who
might have fallen on hard luck and need
some help getting back on their feet I
pitch for the universal basic income
would just be suppose you could take I
forget what the number is but you know
over a trillion dollars of redistributed
spending that the United States
government does Social Security Medicare
Medicaid unemployment all these things
suppose we said okay you can remove all
that and just get some kind of cash
payout if you fall below a certain level
of poverty so this is kind of the Milton
Friedman idea where you get sort of more
and more money the further below the
poverty line you are so you can see the
whole apparatus of the welfare state
with its bureaucracy and inefficiency
and just replace that with a universal
basic income I make that trade every day
of the week yeah do you think that that
would dis incentivize people to actually
the people that are right above that
marker I mean do you know where you put
that markers so I don't know I don't
have the specifics of where I would put
it but yeah the idea is that we so the
way that Friedman structured the idea of
the negative income tax is that you
would still get more total income by
working and making more money so you
would see some decrease in the cash
branch that you get from the government
but it wouldn't be so massive as to
dissin sentiment so they would be
trimmed but they wouldn't be trimmed so
much that you have no incentive to to go
to work yeah do you see that as just
like some sort of inconsistency with the
way that you generally view government
because like it's you're obviously not a
big government guy right and yet this is
something that's really like I would
view this as something that this is like
government should have no place in
giving that much to people like it's
kind of shitty like I'd love to figure
out better ways to help people who need
it the most but the idea of giving more
I just don't know that there's a
it works yeah so there so I think though
that if that objection is successful
would also be successful about against
something like private charity for
example so I think there always is this
worry that when you give some kind of
assistance that this will have negative
effects on people's incentives to work I
think that's I think that's probably
true to some extent but that might just
be a cost that we have to live with so I
think again even if you're doing some
sort of private charity that might
lessen at the margin people's
willingness to go to work but I think
that trade-off is worth it if it means
say that we have people who aren't
starving who aren't very sick without
help but I do I so again a concession
that I won't make because I think by and
large private charity will work much
better than sort of state bureaucratic
charity yeah
or transfer programs at some
philosophical level doesn't that also
make people feel better like the idea
that like right now the government just
does things and it either does them
inefficiently or not you don't really
know where your money's going and you
kind of just are like you can just
easily be like yeah I'm for poor people
because the government's doing it right
where when you actually go ahead and do
things and go ahead and volunteer and go
ahead and give charity and all that that
just philosophically for your own
goodness and happiness and things that
we've talked about that that's probably
much more rewarding I think so right
it's very it's very easy in low cost to
just cast a vote for some policy or
politician that happens to align with
your values that doesn't really you know
the price of that is very low but right
actually say doing some research
figuring out what causes you support
putting money to those things right I
think that's much more gratifying I
think you should get more immortal
credit for doing that just voting for
policies that you like - is that sort of
the basic disconnect between Democrats
and Republicans at this point like I
view it as sort of Democrats are kind of
like we'll just do everything for you
we're gonna say all the nice things and
do it for you and Republicans are just
like we're not we well they end up doing
it anyway because once they're in power
they're always spending the money anyway
but they seem like the evil guys because
they don't want to do it then they do it
anyway but that's what it really comes
down to it's like one set of people who
were saying we're gonna do all the nice
things and then doing them even when the
results aren't nice and another set who
doesn't don't say they want to do the
nice things
than they end up doing it and the result
still aren't great yeah well so so I'm
not sure although I do remember this
book is probably a little old by now
called who really cares by Arthur Brooks
have you ever come across
so he's I think now he's the president I
have no right and what he did find that
there were differences in charitable
giving between Democrats and Republicans
are I'm not sure if it was along party
lines or ideological lines more broadly
and he did find evidence that
conservatives tend to give more
privately than Democrats there might be
a variety of explanations for that so
one explanation might just be that
conservatives tend to be more skeptical
of this the efficacy of these
large-scale bureaucracies like how well
do they actually work I think there's
maybe also this this idea that it's the
role of something like the family or the
church or civil society to take care of
people who are in poverty rather than
the states and so maybe that's why you
see conservatives giving more charitable
dollars than people on the left yeah all
right so I want to finish up with a
couple scientific experiments ok you've
you've written about oh wow I got a
couple here all right let's see how how
sharp you are on the previous work
you've done all right talk to me about
the Stanford Prison Experiment ok
yeah so oh man that's yeah that's going
back right so this was this was research
around here I don't just sit down with
people in mid oh I think you know my
work better than that yeah so that was
an experiment that was conducted I want
to say in the early 70s by a Stanford
psychologist and he recruited more or
less ordinary young men to serve in this
experiment and some of the subjects were
cast as prisoners in this fake prison
and other subjects were cast as the
prison guards in this experiment and so
they were enforcing the prison rules and
feeding the prisoners and having them go
to sleep at specified times and so forth
and to make a long story short what he
found was that the power given to the
students who were the prison guards did
have this corrupting effect so this idea
that power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely seem to be supported
by his experiments so very quickly a
think in a matter of days what you found
were the guards who are again
drawn from the same demographic pool as
the as the prisoners were abusing the
prisoners were mocking them and he had
to cut it short because essentially the
wheels came off of this experiment and
the prisoners got so abuse that prison
guards got so abusive and so this I
think confirms this idea that you don't
have to be a bad person to allow power
to have this corrupting effect on your
behavior yeah there must be plenty of
other studies proving that right even
through just the prison system I mean I
feel like every prison movie I've ever
watched her orange is the new black I
mean the people that are in charge of
the prisons usually are pretty bad
people yeah yeah and like I said they
could be perfectly ordinary and there's
also the the Milgram experiments were
which are kind of the the classic case
of this where you just have people who
are in essence willing to torture give
electric shocks to complete strangers
because somebody in authority told them
to do so and the subjects figure out
ways to rationalize why these electric
shocks are justified make you know the
person should behave differently and
they wouldn't have gotten the shocks and
what's really frightening about this is
it does show that ordinary people people
like you know you and I could easily see
our behavior corrupted given the right
sort of institutions yeah what do you do
as a human knowing that what do you do
to insulate your saying yeah well so one
thing I think is to be very skeptical of
these sorts of institutions which give
people lots of power over others I think
that's one of the big picture
lessons from these sorts of experiments
is just be wary of giving people power
on an individual level knowing about it
I think helps a little bit but even more
than just knowing about it I think
practicing it so when you know that
you're in a position say you to do
something wrong because you feel the
social pressure to do it on a small
level just try to resist that impulse
and actually do the right thing so I
don't think it's the sort of thing that
you can condition yourself to do
overnight to resist malevolent Authority
or resist becoming a malevolent
authority but you could take small steps
but kind of it's like practicing an
athletic skill or something like that
you don't try dunking a basketball the
first time you pick it up but you take
these small incremental steps and you
get better and better
hopefully you build character traits and
then may
resist it when the situation becomes
more dire it's interesting because that
sort of reminds me of the way that we
see virtue signaling happening on social
media these days it's not that we're all
deciding we have this power and we can
shock somebody but it's like you find
someone halfway across the world who
says something you slightly disagree
with even though you've never heard of
them before you start seeing the mob go
at them and then next thing you know you
ratchet up more and then someone else
ratcheted up more and ratchet that more
and it's all done in the name of being
good actually the way you're trying to
shame and destroy this person yeah
they're in there right there's something
kind of psychologically gratifying about
being part of a moralizing mob and I
think that's an impulse that does have
to be resisted right so it's for two
signaling it's not after that's exactly
actual virtue would be saying something
like well I you know I think everybody
here is wrong about what the right thing
to do is here yeah that's a usually a
pretty lonely guy it's true that's true
all right one more sure the Asch
conformity experience yeah so that's
along the same line as the Stanford
Prison Experiment and the Milgram
experiments in this I think this was the
one of the originals it was in the 1950s
and subjects were given a board which
had lines of different lengths on them
so like there was one that was very long
one that was moderately long one it was
short for example and then they were
given another line that they were told
was the same length as one of the lines
on the other board and it was very
obvious so it was like this was a like a
very long line over here and there was a
very long line over here they were
clearly the same length but they were
surrounded by other lines of various
length it was this is very easy test
into the ask subjects well which line
over here is the same length as this
line over here and everybody knew what
the correct answer was but the twist of
the experiment was the experimenter
would bring in Confederates who would
lie and give the obviously false answer
so they would say oh in fact it turns
out that the short line over here is the
same length as this long line over here
and what they wanted to test was whether
the genuine subject would conform to the
mistaken group judgment which they knew
to be clearly wrong or would they stick
to their guns and say no everybody in
this room is wrong it's clearly you know
this line here and everybody
made a mistake and the depressing result
is that many people would not just
conform once but would conform over and
over again to the judgment that then it
was wrong and even people who sometimes
broke from the group would have at least
a couple of answers where the conforms
to the group answer so is that just sort
of basic built in DNA that just certain
people are gonna stand up for what they
believe in what's right and what's true
and and just most of us aren't or is
that can you community even Pinker quite
well I believe Pinker would say
something about a blank slate Yeah right
so I'm not sure right he might he might
say it's something close to our DNA I'm
not sure it's interesting when you read
testimony from people in the Milgram
experiments there were some people who
just refused to deliver these shocks to
people even though there was a lot of
pressure on them and it seems like some
of them had life experiences that really
discourage them from obeying the
authority and it wouldn't shock me no
pun intended if there was something like
that going on in these conformity
experiments where maybe people have seen
the malevolent effects of blind
conformity and this motivated them to do
it so yeah so I'm not sure whether its
nature or nurture I don't know that's
probably above my paygrade right so all
right as long as you mentioned Pinker
this is I think will be a good way to
wrap this all up are you hopeful as as a
philosopher are you hopeful for free
thought I mean a lot of people that care
about the conversations that we're
having are really worried and I find
that the people that are most closely
associated with that I have these
conversations that most I would say most
of us are sort of world weary optimists
that's how I would describe myself like
if I wasn't hopeful I don't know how the
hell I could do this every day right
like I'm hopeful that we can make things
better and yet at the same time there's
no doubt we have an uphill battle and
that there's you know so much hysteria
all the time and all the forces that
that were not in to seem to be on the
march all the time but are you hopeful I
like that term world-weary optimist I
think that probably describes me pretty
well and part of the reason I'm
optimistic is because often times when I
think when you're interacting with
people on a one-on-one level you know
you're
more likely to have a civil productive
discussion about controversial topics
then when it's like these huge you just
gave this talk I think recently at a
college and you got university New
Hampshire you okay right yeah and so I
think in those so talking about like
virtues signaling and a mom mentality I
think those sorts of settings are
conducive to that I think oftentimes
when you're just talking with a person
over a beer you might have completely
different politics than they do but it's
kind of a non-threatening sort of
friendly situation I think people's
guards go down a little bit more in
those sorts of situations and you can
actually have a conversation about
controversial topics in good faith and
so that so I think people want that I
think people want to have these kinds of
discussions and arguments and it might
be the people who are least friendly to
that sort of thing get the most
visibility or get the most publicity but
I think you know if you took an average
person off the street and said hey let's
grab a beer and talk about politics it
wouldn't be nearly as bad as you know
doing it in front of 50,000 people I
agree and that's why I said the thing
about the 80% before and I think in
summation you believe that beer is the
great philosophical equalizer
maybe bourbon I'm not really there's no
I got this great thing over here so yeah
so bourbon is bourbon whiskey that yeah
on that note we should wrap this up and
see what we can do with the bourbon all
right for more on Chris check out see
Fryman dot-com which will link to write
down below
[Music]
you